school choice advocates received a
pretty strong precedent with today's
ruling
on june 30th the u.s supreme court
delivered a major win for school choice
and religious liberty in a case argued
by the libertarian public interest law
firm
the institute for justice writing for
the 5-4 majority chief justice john
roberts declared that a state need not
subsidize private education but once the
state decides to do so it cannot
disqualify some private schools solely
because they are religious
the plaintiff in the case kendra
espinoza was able to send her kids to a
private religious school in montana
thanks to a state scholarship subsidy
program which supplemented the extra
income she made as a bookkeeper and
night janitor in 2018 the montana
supreme court killed that program
on the grounds that it violated the
state constitutional prohibition on
public funding for religious schools
justice roberts found that the montana
ruling
expressly discriminates on the basis of
religious status that decision
strengthens an earlier high court ruling
that upheld the constitutionality of
scholarship programs for sectarian
schools
according to the institute for justice
the decision will have an impact on most
of the 14
states where scholarship students who
want to attend religious schools still
face
legal obstacles i sat down with kendra
espinoza in january
on the eve of her supreme court hearing
how does it
feel to have your name on a supreme
court case because that strikes me as
probably
the hardest way to get into a history
book short of
winning the presidency it's humbling
certainly i had no idea when this case
started that this would ever happen
had no id no way of knowing that we
would be at the u.s supreme court but
to know that our name will forever be on
a court case at the u.s supreme court
that's pretty humbling for sure
tell me the story of how you got here
today it started with
um your girls who wanted to
go to the school of their choice yes so
the girls had
originally been i had homeschooled my
girls prior to them being in public
school
and it was a good fit but life changed
and i had to go to work
and so then i had to put the girls in
school so they were at public school for
a couple of years and
they didn't do terribly but they didn't
do well
and there were struggles there with
other students there were struggles with
what they were learning and i just
didn't feel like they were challenged
enough i didn't feel like
they were going to have as much
opportunity as i wanted for them to have
and they weren't being taught the way
that
i would have taught them at home as far
as their values they were seeing things
that i didn't want them to be seeing so
i started looking at other options and
um found stillwater christian school
was really hopeful that i could put them
there but of course my mind went to wow
how
can this possibly happen there's no way
i can afford this
and um it just took some creativity
and made it happen and now they've been
there for five years
so talk from for me a little bit about
the fact that
i think when people think about school
choice and you know even when you think
about
um the kind of challenges that parents
face sometimes you imagine a more
dramatic situation you think of a kid
who's in
a very unsafe public school or a kid
who's being
you know violently bullied um and i'm
sort of interested in your case and the
fact that you're
the person who's gonna end up bringing
this to the court because
for you it was just more about a bad
fit but i think a lot of parents
identify with that you really do want
the school that's right for your kids
can you
talk about what it was that was the real
distinction between
the public school and stillwater for you
sure because i
i raised my girls in a christian home
and because we had that background of
homeschooling
that christian education was
foundational to me i really wanted them
to be taught the same way that i taught
them at home
i wanted those values to be the same i
wanted them to see things that
we would see at home and and certainly
there's going to be um
challenges that are at a private school
to some degree that there might be at a
public school but
i don't think to the same level and i
just found that it was
the school that the kids at the school
were different than the kids at the
at the private school there's much more
of a family atmosphere
at the private school but the academics
are
so much farther ahead than at the public
school and i just felt like they were
not challenged enough and i wanted
more for them i wanted more
opportunities for them as they grow up i
wanted them to learn
to grow up to be responsible citizens
and contribute to their community around
them but to learn to be
challenged in life and and not just kind
of coast through on things i wanted them
to strive for more
so you mentioned that you were worried
about being able to afford
the school of your choice um walk me
through how the scholarship program
worked um in in montana for you but also
um what other things you looked at in
order to
to afford the school that you wanted
yeah the um the school has
a financial assistance program as well
and then there are the
there's a couple of other scholarship
programs so there's the
big sky scholarships and then a
scholarships and there's an application
obviously process for both of those
and for the financial assistance at the
school
i was working my regular full-time job
and then
i've been working always always had a
second job
at some points i've had three jobs so i
would do
my regular job in the daytime and then
either bookkeeping
or office work from home which is what
i'm doing right now or janitorial
commercial janitorial in the evenings
and on weekends as well
the girls would come and help me with
the janitorial work because that was an
opportunity for them to learn good work
skills and work ethic and learn how to
put effort into something that they want
and so they wanted to continue to stay
at the school it was important to them
and so they were willing to come and
help me
work doing janitorial work on the
evenings and weekends
and how did the scholarship programs
work are those
funded by the state they are not funded
by the state so
the programs that the donors are private
donors contributing to a private
organization
and the donors will get a measly tax
credit at the end of the year so if they
were to contribute 500
to the scholarship organization they
would get a tax credit of up to 150
dollars
but it's not state money it is um
private donations to a private
organization who then looks at the
applications and decides
who is eligible to receive and then how
much they would be eligible to receive
who else is in the scholarship pool with
you and your
girls do you have a sense of the other
families are they all going to religious
schools
there's only one non-religious school in
our valley where we live
as far as montana goes i believe that
the majority of the private schools
are religious schools um i don't know
what the stats are as far as how many
there are but i know that there's only
one other one in our valley and that's
not somewhere that i wanted my girls to
go
the other families they are probably
medium to low income families
i know that all of them are willing to
work hard and they all contribute a
still
a significant amount to their children's
tuition every year just like we do
but that funding that extra bit of
tuition and assistance really does
help our family to be able to continue
to stay there
but for people in your area and maybe
really in your state school choice
necessarily means looking at schools
with a religious affiliation there just
aren't that many correct secular
private options so talk about one of the
key words in this case is
discrimination and i think it's actually
a sort of a difficult thing to be
to be asked to step forward and say
we're being discriminated against um
that there's a long history of court
cases
where um or the supreme court or other
courts have attempted to
sort out the question of what
discrimination is and what it really
looks like
did you experience discrimination would
you say that that's a correct way to
describe what your family has gone
through
absolutely i believe that because
the montana supreme court struck down
the entire program
to ensure that no students of religious
affiliation were to receive these
scholarships
it felt like discrimination because the
whole intent of them
the whole reason that they shut down the
program in the first place was to make
sure that nobody
um of religious background got a
scholarship
would you say that your family is um is
typical of your neighborhood of your
community
um you know is there is there a way in
which
you are um you're different than the
public school population i guess
i'm just interested in um when we think
about school choice we think about
the different needs of different
families how how did you
know that the public schools weren't
right for you and
um and you know what what sort of sets
your family apart from
others that led you to make that choice
i don't
think it was much more than the fact
that we have a faith
i wanted to face faith-based education i
wanted
that same i wanted the same
element of faith and being able to be
able not to pray and being able to
read the bible and study the bible that
was important to me and i think a lot of
the public school there may be other
christians there at the public school
but
that's not how they're taught and they
didn't they're not taught to
the children aren't taught to um
develop their character from a values
perspective they're maybe taught rote
memory and they're taught
some basic academics but they're not
taught from a values-based
perspective at all how do you think what
you're asking for the courts
to to do squares with the values of the
separation of church and state i don't
think there
is an issue there um i believe that
because these funds are donated
privately by private citizens i don't
believe that they know the funds don't
come from the government at all in any
way
i don't believe that a tax credit would
be constituted as public funds
because the money hasn't essentially
ever gone to the
or come from the government even as
someone who follows school choice issues
i actually found that to be a really
surprising and interesting aspect of
this case i think
many people would imagine that what
you and other parents are asking for is
for taxpayer money
to pay for private school that's not the
case here
it's not the case actually in many
school choice programs there have been
other states who have set up similar
models where there's a tax credit or
some kind of incentive for private
charitable giving um do you think people
should be allowed to
give their money as they want or should
there be restrictions on
how people can give charity in general
we are a free country
we should be allowed to give to whomever
we choose to give to
and if there's a program available for a
tax credit
absolutely access that and the fund
those receiving the scholarship funds
should be able to use them where they
choose to
use them what are you anticipating for
next year
for your girls school the same thing and
every year it's that same
question can we afford this can we keep
going we will continue to work hard and
make the extra
income that we need but i just i
anticipate if this
if we win on this case and the funds are
there for the program to continue
then we should be able to make it as we
have been all this time
cost of tuition will go up next year
because naomi will be
in high school so the cost will increase
at that point so
again we have to look at that and look
at our budget and say how much can we
what can we put aside what can we extra
can we bring in or how can we bring in
extra income and you've had a lot of
uncertainty over the last several years
between
the case and just your your family's
kind of changes in individual choices
how does that uncertainty play out for
your family
how does that determine you know how you
think about your future
i have never been one to
panic i suppose i take each day as it
comes
a lot of prayer and just looking at the
budget and i keep a pretty
um pretty tight budget and i watch that
often and
if it's something that we really want
i'm willing to work for it whatever that
takes we're willing to work hard to make
that happen
there comes a point where we can only
work so many extra hours
and so then we really rely on programs
such as this scholarship program
if that's not available and other
programs aren't available then we have
to look at
and consider going back to public school
which wouldn't be
necessarily a good fit for us do you
think there are other kinds of
schools or other types of education that
shouldn't be eligible for this type of
tax credit no i think that if the
program is available
to the general public i think it should
be available to anybody that accesses it
regardless of what school they go to
would you say that you expected to wind
up where you are
now with your family when you started
looking at school options for your girls
no absolutely i didn't know i had no
idea we would end up here
in fact i had no idea that we would even
be involved in any sort of a case
like this and we were approached by the
institute for justice to
partner with them and become a part of
this case
with them and my intent was yes i would
be glad to help out because this
makes a difference for other people not
just for our family and at the time i
wasn't a
us citizen i was a canadian citizen
still but i had legal permanent
residency and i had for up to like 14
years up to that point
but i thought well i can't vote in the
federal election so here's my
opportunity to do something for the
community
had no way of knowing that we would take
it to this
level and that we would be here today so
it's a really
it's a big surprise for us thank you so
much for coming in to talk with us
i really appreciate it kendra thank you